hi everyone I'm really happy to be here
today
I'm a Irina grab of its oil from the
Yale research hey I worked there for the
last three years and our office is
located in Haifa and what is special
about you our research that we develop
algorithms that integrated in Yahoo
products and large-scale systems but we
also publish papers in top conferences
about our work so I I'm from male team
young male team and a lot of projects in
our team are focused on machine
generated main so before I want to
explain what I mean by machine generated
message it's a message that were created
by script by machine and was not written
by a human being for example flight
itinerary order confirmation Facebook
notification and so on so I said that
we're working in your research we do big
data analysis so what are the three big
data real big data sources in the world
can you guess so
photos I saw take it obvious photos and
videos there yeah so the third one is
actually mail as you can get it say this
is much larger than every data source
you can imagine so according to
statistics I found lately in the press
we have about 225 million monthly active
users in Yahoo so you can imagine that
the traffic the volume of the data we
have is really big date and so I said
that we are will talk about machine
generated messages right so guess what
percentage of the messages according to
our analysis in young male is machine
generated and was not written by human
beings
close and it's only increasing 95% of
the data is machine generated okay so
what what is there special about this
data what is characteristics it's highly
structured obviously they it was written
by script and not a person
it has tables right the headers also
attributed large-scale no-one will write
a script a script to generate one or two
messages some scripts used to generate
hundreds of thousands of messages but
it's the opposite of spam this is a
goldmine of personal data there is a lot
of interesting information there that is
very personal about where you're flying
to what you love to buy and so on so we
we want to analyze these data for the
different features we can make in mail
for example we have the smart views in
your mail to show in the different
categories the messages and obviously
it's based on some machine for the
machine generated messages when a people
is actually about the messages that were
not machine generated another
interesting user feature is extractions
so for in extractions lately we care
with a clip coupons a feature everyone
can look on their coupons they see what
they are interested in to clip it and
then leave the table get a notification
your coupon will expire how you can
achieve it how you can make this
automatically so you need the algorithm
behind it that will know how to extract
the data to extract the data is to
locate in the message the fields that
are interesting and also to give a
correct annotation to each field based
on the context for example if they say
unknown and only my's message is there
for example purchased then I want to
know what is the order number if you
will have later the shipment
confirmation and the total price and
what item you purchased so these
projects are all interesting and use the
fact that we use we have a lot of
machines
generated messages we also it's a big
potential for revenue all the targeting
and ads are using also these data to
help show ads that you are interested in
based on what we know about you from
those machine generated messages so the
first step in many algorithms and use
cases for machine generated mail analogy
is to group messages that were generated
created by the same script we have
suggested a new method for clustering
and I will start with the first method
of clustering that also was today's
suggested way in our office by the melty
we call it a template at first we tried
to cluster messages based on the sender
on only the subject on the regex for
example all the messages that came from
amazon.com and the subject is your order
of something has shipped over for a
travel and so on you can maximum several
wildcards but not more sophisticated reg
excel and we we used those kind of
templates of clusters and based on those
clusters we did the clustering gory
extractions but we saw that this method
has several limitations for example it's
not inconsistent okay one template
connect include various mail messages
structures and this is an issue when we
want to do automatic tasks mail mining
also it's incomplete because there's
some messages that has similar contacted
the structure will not associate it
there with the same template is the best
example is when the messages are in
different languages so you can visually
see that the messages I added are from
the same structure and the name of the
user will be in the same location is the
HTML it's a message but the subjects are
in different languages so obviously it
will not be clustered in the same
template
so what my team suggested is to do
structural clustering a clustering based
on the structure of the body we called
it X cluster and it relies on the
message Dom tree when they say Dom tree
I mean about the schema HTML ephemera of
the message on this HTML that's not the
content itself because it will be
different from message to message but
the HTML because it was created by
script will be the same right and it
represented by hash signature I will
just say that this algorithm is linear
and very simple and scalable it was very
important because I started with regulat
it is really big data we can use some
may be more sophisticated clustering
methods but they will be slower high
latency not something we can allow
ourselves so this is very fast algorithm
and also efficient so this is example of
two messages that I expect to be in the
same X cluster as you see the
information inside is not the same right
this product is different from that
product but the structure is exactly the
same at first you have the name of the
user you have here's the address
and the product he purchased and the
price so let's go by an example I will
show you how this algorithm works
this method of clustering was published
in a paper a few years two years ago I
think I will give the reference at the
end of the presentation so let's assume
we received this a simple a message and
we want to know that it belongs to the X
plus tur with that signature ok and we
don't know anything about other messages
this all we have first we will look on
each edge it's HTML Dom tree ok and we
will focus only on the passes that ends
with textual node and do you understand
right
II don't have a question how to
transform these to the HTML Dom tree you
want me explain about it ok and then I
just travels
the tree and I create ordered lists of
exposes a expose is actually just a
concatenation of the HTML tags in the
past to the textual leaf when I have the
ordered list of exposes I will just run
some a hash function on the string and I
will receive my signature that will
represent the X cluster that this
message belongs to okay so you see it's
linear it's very relatively fast and
it's scalable you don't need to see all
the messages you can do it concurrently
this is the current algorithm we are
using for clustering questions yeah so
if you use cases after the clustering is
automatic right you don't care you will
just for example for the classification
I will explain now I will receive new
expositors that were changed right the
message will belong to X plus tur 1 and
then it now it belong to X cluster 2 and
I will generate the features for the
classification and I will receive the
just what is the category of the current
X cluster the question was is that the
obviously the data is changing the
templates can be changed and then a
similar content we will be classified to
different X cluster and I said that if
the use cases later to extracted data to
classify the data are automatic then I
don't care I received a message I know
what its category what is the data how
to extract it and then ok so as a hash
signature is only used for the
algorithms after it so this was my first
research project yeah
it can be millions a day but I'm not
sure I can share the exact numbers yeah
yeah it's a lot of big splashes yes yeah
so it can be it can be clustered to
different clusters right but we also I
didn't prepare this inside this
presentation but it is appears in the
paper we published we also have methods
to combine several exposures together
for example four repetitions because
when we do the X cluster we care about
the order of the tags we add also index
if it was a header one header two it
will receive different expense we saw
that if we remove the indexes we call it
naked X Luster's then if for example if
you have the same message but it's
someone bought one product someone
bought two product and someone else for
it will be still the same naked X
plaster if we remove the indexes because
the exposes will look the same also we
can have some eddy distance between the
exposes to allow a larger combination of
X clusters but for the automatic use
queues of male classifications I did it
based on the X clusters I I don't care
how many clusters I received by it still
amount a high amount of messages in each
X cluster to be able to classify them
while you will use the expand of the
because we wanted to extract textual
data and it was what we are we
interested on in maybe we could they a
detect as the images I think it would
work not less than the current algorithm
okay so as I said this was my first
research project in Yahoo and my goal
was given an X cluster of messages to
classify to categories so here you here
you will see the categories they used by
it was defined by the product and this
is not the it's a random sample of X
clusters right distribution it's not the
traffic okay so in travel you can see
it's only 2% but actually it means that
they have two percent of different
structures exclosures and a lot of other
and we saw it's usually social messages
like Facebook linking that has a lot of
structures it is the other category so
the interesting categories that I wanted
to classify the x+ ters based on the
clusters is marketing purchases finance
events travel and services so I will
give you a high level on the process of
the classification and I will go deeply
inside each of the steps so I received
the cluster of messages and like in many
machine learning tasks I want to
generate the features here's the
features obviously are aggregated from
all the messages okay and I will go into
it deeply inside what features were used
and also the label data right I want my
seeds not looks well hey I see for each
X cluster for example amazon.com five
seven beers on the signature it was
labeled as shopping based on a sample a
few samples of messages and so on when I
have the features in the label data I
can learn run the training
process and to do the classification it
is a tutorial based on messages that are
anonymized or human renewable that users
opt-in that we can use their messages
okay so important part of this project
was to understand what features to use
in order to be able to cluster the
obvious feature types are content just
take the words and use them but also we
saw that important symbols like money
symbols airport names were really
important here and due to the fact that
we aggregated it based on many messages
then if you have also Airport code like
Sun s UN if it's appear in one message
you are not sure if it's Sun or a Sunday
at the airport code but here you have
Instagram of airport code and if I see
that I have a lot of appearances from
airport codes
it is a strong signal for my learning
algorithm also user actions here again
they moved to folder and also the name
of the folder if it has indicated name
it's a very strong feature it's not
something I could achieve if I were
using only single message because most
of the users will not use folders it's
rare action to move the folder and to
give it a indicating their name but even
if you I have 100 thousands of messages
in the X cluster and one percent of the
users gave the folder indicating name
it's enough for all the messages or all
the cluster to help to label it
according to the correct category
traffic a traffic is another type of
features I for example in marketing we
saw that the message has the the
messages are sent in bursts there is a
traffic in the volume of the messages
and then it goes down on the other hand
and purchases it is not a marketing
campaign user can buy in every time and
it is not that you don't have the burst
in the traffic in the volume also the
weekend can be different from the you
days of the week so it was also
something we wanted to capture using
those features we also took the address
the center a name has a domain and we
tried to locate indicating words inside
the center like in tickets reserved
ations you can see that if you separate
it to two words it can help you with the
classification and last features that is
mostly available using those effect that
we work with clusters that are
structural we also count how deep is a
expose deep I mean how many HTML tags
you have inside because personal
messages usually will be much shallow
than the machine generated it has a lot
of tables GRE and so on also a variable
and constant expose if you look on the
message based on the X clusters some of
the best a story in the X percent of the
message some expresses will have
constant value for example thank you for
your order it will be the same for all
the message in the thousands of messages
it will be thank you for your order and
if you have the a high era hideout on
Hainan it will be different from all the
messages I will call it variable X s so
the percentage of variable x position
constant expresses also indicates that
it is for example marketing because it
will be will help more constant exposes
ok so those were the features and now
let's go to the learning process so we
had a model for each category and
trained one versus all that mean that
for from example for travel I took the
labels as positive and all the other
categories were negative and non travel
the same for marketing those that are
labeled as marketing are positive and
all the others are not marketing we're
on a logistic regression algorithm and
prediction based on the highest score
for each model we receive the score
based on the procedure America we wanted
we
find what is a minimum score we allow if
all the models will receive scores these
lowers and the limit we will say the
categories other it's not one of the
categories we want to label so now what
training data to take let's recall the
distribution way so let's assume we do a
random sample of 1000 X clusters and we
want to label them we will receive only
to a very small amount of travel and
services and Finance but most of the
extra cells will be other it's not that
interesting right we want to focus on
the interesting categories so how we did
it we had around six and a half thousand
X fasters in there that were labeled we
sampled only 20% as a random because we
still wanted to see the real traffic
right so others other is also
interesting because we want our model to
be able to separate the other so we
wanted to have those categories in our a
training set but we also received 80% of
the X clusters for labeling distributed
equally over all categories the same for
the test we did it equally distributed
between the X clusters and the way we
did it is by few iterations we train the
model based on heuristics orders noisy
labels and based on his its
classification we could sample the
examples because we had a noisy label
based on the first version of the model
then it was improved after adding more
label data and then we could again
increase the amount of labels based on
the improved model output important note
is that this algorithm requires only a
week of data in order to classify with
pretty high precision recall the
features are aggregated over a week and
it's a short learning cycle we have
another algorithm a that class
based on the center and it required a
three months of data or something to be
aggregated here we have enough
information enough messages in a week
and we try to test in different weeks
for three months if the cluster is a
category for specific extra stress
remains stable remains the same because
if one X cluster is quiet in one week it
clustered as marketing and week after
clustered like us travel and two weeks
later it will be clustered as the events
something is not working here okay so it
proved us that it's the reasonable that
because labels remain stable for the X
plus turns before I go to the evaluation
I guess maybe for most of you it's clear
adjust to want to make sure we all
understand the matrix the matrix are
simple precision Rico
so if we have in the image on the left
as if let's assume the full dots are the
x close to that classified as travel and
they the empty dots are the dots lakes
clusters that were classified as non
trouble in the circle in the middle are
the X plus ters at my model classified
as travel so you see the light green is
the correct okay
that is why my precision of my
classification is a light green divided
by the amount of results I classified us
travel on the other hand it's not enough
right because I can give only when the
i1 99% sure that it's the travel I will
classify as travel but then I will miss
most of the travel X plus s that is why
I also need Zaire Rico Rico captures how
many relevant items are selected so I
will divide the amount of travel items
that I classified ice travel divided by
the total amount of travel I had in the
data my truth this will be my Rico so
you understand that precision Oracle is
a trade off it based on the minimal
limit I will select for the model if I
select very low
limit for my models for travel for
example then I will almost every example
will be classified air travel even if
I'm not one sure I will classify it as
travel and then my wrinkle will be high
because I will classify many examples as
travel and probably I will capture
almost all the trouble but my precision
will be much lower right if I go up in
the air Rico my precision will be lower
because if I may limit for the model
score is low then many non travel will
be also classified as travel and the
other side is obviously putting too high
limit on my model is also not the best
way because my precision will be high
but I will classify so low amount of
good examples that it's not very useful
that is why we for each category we
selected the limit to receive the very
basic results of around 90 percent
precision Rico you can see that it was
the hardest category was purchases
mostly because it was confusing with
other categories like finance the
examples I remember I remember confusing
for me and the editors were with people
because in the paper receipt you have
the item you purchase but it's actually
finance and not purchase so it's not
very clear sometimes how to classify and
it was also a little bit confusing for
our my classifiers so but I believe
those results are good enough ok so the
conclusions I talked about clustering
machine generated messages using the
structure we saw that the structure is
important because the header a way of
templates
he has limitations I presented the
classification use case with the 95 90
precision Oracle rates that are
considered good rates for the
classification with a short cycle of for
learning only one week a my current
project is fully automated mail
extraction
as I mentioned before after I classified
and I know that it's trouble I want to
be able to extract travel and related
fields like what his location user
travels to when he travels or currently
we finished with the coupons that is why
we came with a clip the coupon I feel so
you understand that in order to be able
to matically extract the data you also
need first to classify the cluster to
know what fields you want to extract
right if it's purchase you will extract
the product if it's travel you will
extract the location it's very different
so just if you want to know more about
the project we do you can go to a paper
in wine it and this is my team he will
do besides the machine generated
projects we also have a lot of projects
related to search in mail also papers
that were published published these
papers this presentation is based on
mainly on two papers that were published
in the international conferences and you
have here much more details and I
covered here and last but not least
obviously the results here direct from
analysis on young male data aggregated
or originally from obtained users we
preserve user privacy
obviously in such sensitive data it's
male so it's important even though we
publish the papers will also always
think about these issues thank you